book tv
you're watching book tv
coming up next monique demery recounts
the 1963 coup in south vietnam that led
to the execution of president no din
diem and the exile of the de facto first
lady madame new who spent many decades
in seclusion miss demery found madame
new in paris where the woman dubbed the
dragon lady and trusts the author with
her unpublished memoirs this is about 45
minutes
[Applause]
well um
i'm glad to look out to the audience and
see that actually there are a lot of
people i'm sure who actually was alive
just like me during the vietnam war and
remember who madame knew was i mean i
was born after her but her
exile but still i was born into the war
and my family uh know quite a bit about
that history um but monique i have to
say that um
what surprised me most uh especially now
listening to the introduction
is that
here is someone who actually was sent
out of vietnam be
because of her
relationship with the gold family and
her role in the war but into 1963
and you graduate in 2003
um
why would you be interested in madame
new
who wouldn't be interested in madame neu
she um from an early age just captivated
me everything that i had come to know
about vietnam i was i was born in 1976
so after the war had ended and um my
father narrowly missed being drafted
into the war and so for me vietnam was
this sort of images and books of
um of all the terrible images of war
that my generation of america has come
to associate with vietnam and nothing
about
what a beautiful or interesting country
it was it was really just defined for me
as the war so to see madame news picture
jump out and um especially you know i
think the captions called her the face
of evil or something i had to know more
well um before we get to her
there is a narrative that runs parallel
in the book which is your own
relationship with her and your search
for madame new and i think in some way
as a journalist who's been working for
20 years plus i
the investigative part is what i find
really intriguing because you didn't
know her address and here you are in
paris searching for her from sort of
very loose pieces of information that
you've seen tell the audience about this
sure so
if my husband was here he would tell you
that i'm very
persuasive um and i really was
determined to find madame new in all of
my sort of initial research i expected
to find an obituary and
there was not nothing there so um
everything i could sort of gather was
that madame new was still alive and
living in rome
um i spoke to a journalist from the new
york times who had spoken to her and he
said yep as far as i know she's still
living in rome
so um a few people i've talked to a few
people here tonight about how i very
much tried to study vietnamese and
humbly
humbly admit that i didn't do a very
good job of keeping up with it but for a
while i was practicing and part of my
practicing is i would go online and pull
these
vietnamese language articles and try to
translate them and sort of keep my
skills fresh well one of these articles
um was written by a vietnamese man
living in the united states who claimed
he had interviewed madame new
i'd never heard of this guy i had never
heard of his journal it was a it was a
catholic vietnamese uh website
and um but all of a sudden all of these
sort of light bulbs went off in my head
and when he was talking about
interviewing her he said something about
seeing the eiffel tower through her
kitchen window and i had already known
that there was an apartment madame new
had gone to after um after she left
saigon and it was an apartment in paris
that was just at the foot of the eiffel
tower so it kind of struck me that huh
you know maybe maybe she is back there
maybe it's not so crazy so um long story
short i looked around paris for any tall
buildings i could find around the eiffel
tower
and there aren't that many so i started
knocking on doors and very persistently
uh spoke to a concierge who said
no no you know she's she's not here
she's next door
but that was not the end of it because
of course um i mean in some way um in
the book um she's portrayed a little bit
like marlon dietrich this mysterious
woman who won't talk to anyone i don't
see anyone and in some way your your
story is about
finding her meeting her and also trying
to capture
who she is um so
it was a long
process of
being in touch with her
so please tell us it was almost like a
courtship honestly um i tried to
first i tried to really impress her and
seemed very business-like and smart but
she just put me in my place immediately
you know because i was young and naive
and what could i possibly know um so
this is on the phone right this is all
on the phone exactly um matt so the
the first time that madame knew called
me um
i wasn't expecting her to call i'd been
writing her letters for months i had
been you know i had knocked on her door
that day i mean i had done everything um
except for see her and she called me out
of the blue
so she dictated very early on the terms
of our relationship
when she would call who she would leave
messages with um how how i should
address her very specific things
and in fact in that first conversation
that we had she was really curious about
about not so much me but
why was i why was i interested in her
you know who in your family works for
the cia who's a government agent i was
like no one i'm just i'm just curious
so um
slowly i um
so part of it was the the first day that
she called me my husband and i had been
trying to get pregnant and it had been a
long process
that morning i had taken a pregnancy
test and found out i was pregnant so i
was overjoyed and before i could even
wake up my husband to tell him madam new
is calling me on the phone so i'm like
i don't know
um but so part of this i think
making her
getting her humanity out was i told her
early on you know that this had happened
and this sort of coincidence and right
away she was like oh it's not
coincidence it's a sign from god right
this is meant to be so there was this um
and then it developed into a very sort
of maternal thing she would always call
and ask about the children and
we would really get into the
nitty-gritty of motherhood madame knew
breast fed each of her children for at
least six months she told me and you
know she was very precise about about
all of those things that i wouldn't
imagine the dragon lady to
be well before we get to the dragon lady
narrative i i'm just curious how many
people in the audience actually knows
who who who she is madame knew oh my
that's quite a lot um that's not not
your typical readers i don't think uh
these days but who knows um yeah so can
you tell us
in a few short
sentences
a framework of who she is and why she's
important in the vietnam history
sure well
madame new was the first lady of south
vietnam from 1954 to 1963.
and she was first lady on a bit of a
technicality her
brother-in-law was the president noting
ziem and ziem was a
very um
moral
uh very catholic he was married to his
country really so he he never took a
wife um so instead it was madame new was
his younger brother's wife and his
younger brother
no new did all of the politicking that
uh zm
couldn't or wouldn't do all of this sort
of unsavory business of running a
country with an iron fist um so
everything from running the secret
police to um
uh
recruiting youth
and running the the
political party
and madame new was really the face of
the regime because she was beautiful she
was the hostess she was she was smart
she was well spoken and so
um i think initially the media was was
charmed by her she was so young too when
she became first lady she was 30 years
old
yeah but in some way she
i hate to put it in this way but her
career went up went up in flame i mean
unintentionally literally uh because of
the self-immolation and what she
actually said and this is what in some
way unfortunately is what she's
remembered by
absolutely so um
in 1963 is really when she got the most
press she was on the cover of
the saturday evening post
newsweek
uh life magazine
i mean you name it madam news on the
cover of it and it wasn't for anything
good it was um as andrew was saying in
the summer of 1963 there was a buddhist
crisis in vietnam and um the buddhists
were um speaking out against the zm
regime
and
the zyan regime was
not responding in a way that was very
good pr madam knew you know i'm
paraphrasing but she said sort of oh
good you know a monk is self-immolating
great we'll have a barbecue she was sort
of like a marie antoinette um she came
across as very cruel and at that time
all of
all of america knew of vietnam really in
this sort of loose way like oh yeah
we're
helping these people we're saving them
from communism and we're doing this
really good thing
and here was um
here is suddenly a very ugly dark side
to the regime that the americans were
helping so
well one thing i didn't know uh was that
she actually was not raised catholic um
and in fact converted when she married
uh no new um i had always thought um
being french as she was um francis and i
i'm not sure but she was a franciscan
her father was yeah that they are
naturally sort of converting to
catholicism but in fact they were
buddhists and this is an interesting
thing because you know a lot of
vietnamese families are sort of split in
many ways and the religious device is
definitely part of it my my father for
instance was raised catholic and my mom
was raised buddhist and there's a lot of
family that sort of split along that
line but to see her being so
pro-catholic and um supportive of a
regime that cracked down on buddhism was
a little bit shocking in a way for
someone who was raised buddhist um but
can you talk about the religious
divisions in vietnam um
that time yeah
a little bit um so yes madam new was
raised she was raised in hanoi for most
of her life she was she was born in
hanoi um went way down to the southern
um very tip of southern vietnam and then
went back to hanoi and i hadn't known
until i was researching this book that
she was actually north vietnamese by by
birth and heritage um because the regime
then um that was the was the south
vietnamese regime um but the religion uh
so she converted at her marriage which
was in 1943
and
madame news mother was a devout buddhist
and
didn't there was a lot of tension
between mother daughter
and i think the fact that madame knew
married a catholic um i think her mother
honestly maybe looked a little bit down
at her for that and i think that madame
knew in her own way was like huh now i
can start fresh
and not have to worry about
about that parental
judgment all the time
new always
teased his wife actually and called her
his little heathen um because because
she was new to catholicism she was
baptized um on the day before her
the night before her wedding was her
baptism so he he liked to tease her but
later in life i think for madame knew
that was really her defining
um characteristic it was how she really
made sense of her life was by putting it
into this religious framework
but she was also involved in a writing
law during the
um
herring i suppose um and part of that
has to do with her own
insecurity that's what you discussed in
in in the book
and
it's interesting because um she actually
had her own sister incarcerated because
of part of the reason uh has to do with
her sister wanting a divorce
yes so this was sort of the scuttlebutt
in saigon um was that so
uh madam new was elected to the uh
to the to the senate so she was a member
of the legislator legislature but of
course no one would say no to her i mean
you know she came up with a law and
people were quick to pass it um and and
madame knew had some very good points i
mean i don't think that all of her laws
were totally reactionary she saw um she
saw that the communists were
making great gains by taking women
seriously and until madame new changed
the law
women in south vietnam were not able to
own property they were not able to own
their own bank accounts
so madame knew
made progress in in a sense in that she
saw a section of the population that was
being excluded
she um
she also
saw that the communists were doing a
good job of sort of taking the war
seriously so as as more and more uh
foreigners americans came into south
vietnam madame didn't want it to seem
like it was sort of a party city
she um
she wanted people to be like hey we're
at war like let's take this seriously so
she banned um prostitution she banned
gambling she banned dancing she banned
underwire bras she banned all sorts of
stuff um
and the one sort of big big thing was
she banned divorce
and the theory was at the time that she
was trying to prevent her sister her
older sister from getting a divorce
um
and
uh
the rumor was madame new would never
really acknowledge us
the rumor was that uh
when madame knew
wouldn't grant her sister
you know outlawed divorce in the country
which meant that lychee couldn't
couldn't get a divorce she slit her
wrists and went running through the
palace and madame new had her imprisoned
in the hospital
uh which is interesting because vietnam
was is full of rumors and there's a lot
of this sort of narrative that goes
around um
and and part of that uh has to do with
the fact that there's no way to
validate certain things
um
but
how would you characterize her i mean
you you mentioned in in your book about
her own feeling of being isolated and
her husband
uh was a philanderer in a way uh in many
ways i mean he actually had a girlfriend
right and uh
and uh
we'll talk about that and we'll get to
the next question sure so um
i think we all
could be guilty of sort of rewriting our
own history in our heads
um i i remember what i did yesterday in
a very positive light but you know the
guy whose seat i stole on the bus might
not feel the same way
i guess what i'm trying to say is by the
time madame new was in her 80s she
remembered her life
very specifically and it was as a
devoted wife and everything i did was
for my husband
um but the diary that i found uh that
she wrote that was my next question but
go ahead
i'll tell you about this diary but but
in this diary she you know all of that
kind of um
rose-colored glass
reflection is gone and she talks about
how hard it was to be married to someone
who cared so much about um building this
new
political philosophy if that's what you
can call it um
he also apparently did have someone else
on the side someone that madame knew you
know thought was
below him and and certainly below her
um
so these little accusations came out
in the journal
um so yes um there's a lot of tidbits
that i find titillating because there's
so much sex going on in the book
which came i mean it's not a surprise
but the fact that
there is some recording of it or some
observation of it um is interesting
including
this conservative family that madame new
came from which is
you know um the parents her parents who
are you know really upstanding from this
really respectful
and the mothers from uh you know royal
family but in fact the mother is having
sex with a bunch of different people
which is like
wow
[Laughter]
that was great the french are very good
at this because um of course the french
are
when i was in the archives in france um
i i would i would find references to
madame new's mother um having slept with
the right french men at the right times
and then when the japanese were coming
in having slept with the right japanese
men at the right time and taking
japanese lessons and going out to dinner
with the japanese and so um
it was
it it's very possible that the french
man who was writing it down was you know
had his advances spurned and was bitter
and so decided that that would be her
legacy but
considering that this came from a couple
different sources um it there was
probably something there she used what
she had to get ahead and to save her
family no the sex is not shocking the
fact that it's recorded it is i mean
because uh sex in all kind of you know
royal courts down to you know presidency
is is the norm but but the fact that the
french are going to these parties and
recording it is shocking and that's my
other question i always wanted to know
since you're half french
and you're you're viewing vietnam
through the french lens as much as an
american one what is it that the french
know about vietnam that the americans
still don't
oh good
question uh
i'm not sure that that question still
is is true today i think that um there's
a lot of nostalgia in france for this
idea of ando sheen
and um i i know that my mother so my
mother was born in uh 1946. so for her
growing up she um
she grew up learning that indochina was
a part of france and and feeling you
know quite quite a bit of pride in that
in that empire and to think that i'm i'm
born in 76 so 30 years later and that's
totally bewildering to me that um
that she could have assumed
that so i'm i'm not sure that the
question today of what do the french
know and what don't they know
i think it's really misplaced sort of
colonial
nostalgia
um
let's get back to the role of a powerful
woman in the world of politics of the
60s
she seems such an anomaly in a world
full of men
and even
jackie
onassis jacqueline and kennedy
looked down at her for being involved in
politics so she was not ladylike and
certainly among uh first ladies of asia
during that time the idea of this woman
with a gun and you know speak her mind
regardless what the men were saying uh
and even you know tell the president to
shut up was something really shocking
not just to
asian but the world in a way and yet
there she was sort of uh blabbering her
her ideas without any sense of
inhibition
right well the the first one before
madame knew there was madame shanghai
sheck and she um she was schooled in
america she i think she even had a
southern accent they say because she
went to college in georgia um
and she she was very well spoken but she
also had a feeling for what america and
americans were looking for in a first
lady and madame knew didn't have that i
think she
um
i do think that madam knew would have
looked for her place in the world
but there was no role model for her
there was not there was no shoes for her
to to step into to follow so she really
had to kind of forge her own way and
blunder her way through it um and i do
think that the dynamic with the kennedy
family
and the ngo family in saigon is a
fascinating one two catholic families um
very much family regimes right there's
jfk and
his family and ziem and his family and
then there's madame new who's this young
first lady beautiful glamorous and
jackie in the white house and um both of
them sort of francophile we can say and
um and jackie did she in in these
interviews that have come out
where she's asked about madame new she
says you know oh she's horrible she
she's she's everything that jack found
just ugly because she wasn't submissive
she wasn't quiet and jackie
characterized her own marriage as an as
an asian marriage whatever that means
but that she was
she was subservient to her husband
but of course the other irony of course
is that when jim was murdered kennedy
was murdered not very long after and
there is this letter that madame you
actually sent to her because madame you
felt very betrayed by the americans and
talk about that letter and and the
bitterness that's involved sure um
oh goodness where do i start uh
first i i guess for those of you that
don't know um kennedy gave the okay for
a coup in vietnam for a regime change in
vietnam in august of 1963. and there
were several false starts in saigon um
and the coup didn't actually happen
until november madame knew was in the
united states at that time and no
american officials would meet with her
the only
public official who met with madame new
on her trip here to the united states
was the director of police in new york
city because he had to guarantee her
safety people were throwing things at
her um and so she uh
she she felt really slighted that here
she was first lady and no one was paying
any attention or giving sort of giving
her her proper due
and she knew that a regime change in
vietnam couldn't have happened without
the okay from kennedy and kennedy's
administration so she did she felt very
betrayed and and she made this like
eerie proclamation as she's getting on
the plane um to leave the country she
said
again i'm paraphrasing um something like
i predict that the story with vietnam is
only at its beginning you know america
will have this like long
history with vietnam
and she was right i mean we were we were
there another decade um
which is of course the irony is that we
she's vilified a lot of ways in the
media and yet she was right in a lot of
ways about the future and america's
relationship with vietnam
yes and she said things that were hard
to say at the time she um
she accused the buddhists who were
rising against the dm regime of being
very loosely organized and therefore
ripe for communist infiltration which
the americans would find out later
at least in 66 and 68 that that that
would come to be the case she just
called it early and kind of
inappropriately um she also accused uh
the american press of being uh
infiltrated by the communists um i
actually i'll use her favorite word
intoxicated yeah um everybody was
intoxicated by the communists um and in
that case too she actually wasn't so
wrong there were
uh
there were
aids informers working for the americans
um that were you know part of the
communist system
yum um
very famous one uh who actually worked
with stanley carnell yes some phantom
and yeah yeah um
i was thinking of her uh this morning
and then saw a lady gaga video and i
thought in in a strange way she was a
lady gaga of politics of the 60s because
of the things she's saying that's so
shocking you know you know barbecue
monks you know and and that sort of
thing
shocked the world but people are no
longer shocked by lady gaga so i was
thinking of
had she had good public relation and in
a different context you know maybe the
the
the courses of events in vietnam might
have even changed because she influenced
so much of the public opinion
so can you talk about the context
of this now in relationship to her being
a woman back then what would madam new
have tweeted
140 characters it either would have
gotten her in a lot of trouble or it
would have saved her
in some sense um
yeah maybe not lady gaga maybe like
lindsay lohan or something you know
watching someone go off the rails but
madame new really was this first kind of
paparazzi not first but she was
definitely one of the few political
um
people that that
the the media was so fascinated with her
just kind of daily
what was she wearing what was she saying
that kind of thing
let's get back to your relationship with
her because i find it really interesting
that in the end you actually never
really met her in person
how how
how does one
write a book about someone who once
spent you know
countless amount of hours dreaming
thinking and obsessing with that person
and actually never met her until when
she and of course she died and then so
how how is that relationship and how
does that inform your writing
well i think um i always thought that i
would meet madame new and when i uh
started this book
uh we and finally started talking to her
we would set up these really elaborate
meeting plans and again all on her terms
you know i know this church around the
corner and it's dark and we'll meet by
the st joseph statue there's a park it's
really discreet no one will see us all
these kind of cloak and dagger things um
and she would ask me to bring my
children and i did sort of thinking oh
that would make me seem um sweet and
naive and like i wasn't gonna hurt her
because i really was just just curious
but she stood me up at each of these
each of these things and and i
um
she always said you know i'm really
sorry you know there was always a reason
and really i had no power in this
relationship she was dictating the terms
and so
you know if i wanted to if i wanted to
continue to talk to her i knew it would
be on her terms there was a time when
madame news stopped accepting my phone
calls and stopped speaking to me
and that was because um i talk about it
a bit in the book but i'd asked her
something that she thought was
inappropriate or
in fact i had told her that something
was you know inappropriate and she hung
up on me and we didn't talk again for
about a year um but right before she
died uh so she died in um actually on
easter sunday um of 2011 which just is
so perfect for her um because she really
like i said she was so um
quiet she was so catholic and believed
in the resurrection and i i think um for
her to pass away on easter was
was just perfect for her um but she
before she died she knew that the end
was coming and she sent me her memoirs
and she had written three volumes
each of them
several hundred pages and they were all
about sort of the
the mystery of life and and it was
totally dense with
uh biblical references and things i
couldn't really understand but then
peppered in there were these narratives
of her life as a child so
at the end i feel like i kind of got
what i what i wanted from her which was
her own in her own words a recollection
of her
of her life and and the meaning of her
life which even though i didn't
necessarily understand it she believed
very very strongly that she was um
predestined to have led this life
her life is quite tragic in many ways
because not only
did she lose a country but she lost her
husband
and then her children um die from
accidents two of the four
um
a lot of vietnamese actually talk about
uh
her being cursed for the role she played
during the war but um what do you make
of that and how what does she make of
her own tragedy i'm back to the kennedy
thing i mean it's like
there's people talking about the kennedy
curse there was the the no the no family
curse um certainly madam new had a very
uh
tragic life so first in 63 she was
disowned by her parents who she wasn't
getting along with anyways then um
her husband is killed in a coup a couple
years later in the 60s her oldest
beloved daughter dies in a car crash
and things keep getting worse in 1986
her parents lived in georgetown and they
were murdered by her brother um so
and then only just last year in 2012 her
youngest daughter um the daughter that
she's famously she she would dress her
up in these little paratrooper outfits
and um
and dress her up like a little soldier
and she she passed away as well in an
auto accident in italy so just a really
you know
bad chain of events yeah
um
do would you like to read a passage um
perhaps something about your own
relationship and your struggle to
connect with her sure yeah i'd be happy
to and i um i i do want to say that this
book was
it was hard to figure out the structure
of the book because i
wanted to be as candid as i could about
madame new and how
how she played me and how she was how
she was this sort of unreliable narrator
but at the same time the best person
that i could talk to about her life um
so i tell madame news story i tell my
story of finding her and i hope that i
tell a story also of um those years of
the vietnam war that are confusing to
people of my generation but um this is a
this is just a little section um
about when i i thought we might meet
we should meet madame news said on the
phone shortly after tommy's birth it was
the first time she had expressed any
willingness to meet me face to face she
must have reasoned that i couldn't
possibly be conspiring to hurt her if i
was with a baby so she insisted that i
bring tommy would paris be all right
i was i was planning a september trip to
introduce the baby to my french
relatives a stop in paris would be on
the way i didn't tell madame new i was
also planning to visit the french
colonial archives in the south of france
to see what other history i could pull
up by this time i knew how firmly madame
new believed that her version of the
truth should be adequate and reported
unchallenged even when it had obvious
cracks
she planned the time and place our
meeting was to take place in the iglis
sanyon a catholic church not far from
her apartment in the 15th arjunismo we
would meet in the nave in front of saint
joseph's statue at 10 am then we can go
to the park across the street to talk it
will be very discreet
when i got inside the church the
vault-like doors closed behind me
shutting out the bright sun i thought
belatedly that perhaps i should be
worried i reminded myself that i was
just introducing tommy to a little old
lady what could happen sure she had been
the dragon lady she had run a militia of
armed women and had her husband's
henchmen at her disposal but she had
also been a mother four times over over
i forced myself to focus on that aspect
but i was ill at ease i told myself i
was just nervous about making a good
impression
and i think i told you all she stands me
up and and uh
and we're not there but just the the end
is um when we spoke next she didn't
actually apologize not in so many words
but her voice sounded contrite enough
and of course i forgave her the next
time we would meet in her apartment she
said i believed her i waited an hour in
the lobby this time but she didn't let
me up the elevator i forgave her again
she told me a woeful story she wasn't
sure she could trust anyone again i
would have to prove myself the dragon
lady was keeping herself tantalizingly
out of reach
um in your discovery of madame new you
also discovered vietnam
and for someone who was born in 1976 um
after the war ended um
vietnam for most people of your
generation really is not that clear or
as extensive as your research um
what what do you think
americans don't understand about vietnam
still after all these years and after
your research what do you feel like you
discovered most about vietnam and its
history
great question
i think that for i can only speak for
people of my generation um and i can't
speak for everybody but i will try to
speak for myself and what i see
is that um the war was so massive and so
tragic that to boil it down into the
distinct parts of
what we were trying to accomplish why we
were there who were we helping who are
we who whose side was on whose side it
was so confusing that i think it's
better to just say
vietnam and sort of leave it
so what i really tried to do in my book
was to find one narrative
one story to get in and give a little
clarity about
what was going on in this woman's life
and how perhaps
a person of my generation can relate to
that in
whatever way um
well i can tell you uh from reading the
book is that
it really helped my thinking about
vietnam in some ways because
a lot of these things this rumor this
gossip goes on within my own family as
as the years roll down
and i've become completely american but
when i go home to my parents you know
the old ruling class of vietnam the
french-speaking people
this kind of narrative still goes on at
the dining table
but it goes on as private conversation
and i never thought one day that they
actually find a way out in into the the
limelight as a mainstream conversation
in american households so i i find that
really intriguing because i thought wow
there's all this stuff that i could
write about as well that you know maybe
people are interested in you know even
going back further um but then are you
my my last question before we open up is
that um
are you done with vietnam or are you
still interested and if so what's next
for you
this book was really a labor of love i
started
shortly after i graduated from harvard
in 2003
and it took me a while to meet her and
then it took me a while to woo her and
then
i had to figure out how i was gonna
write the book so
i'm kind of
just gonna
promote my book for a while and talk
about madame new because i put a lot of
time into it so i want for a lot of
people to know her story
and then we'll see i
i would really like to bring my kids to
vietnam um that for me would be just
sort of the next step but as i was
telling andrew before i'm not sure how
this book is going to be received in
vietnam
um
there's a chance that it may not go over
well so i'm just i'm really very curious
to see
if if uh if i'm allowed back
yeah
we'll we'll have to wait and see
all right but i can guarantee you that
it was going to be pirated and so right
next to the lonely planet just like my
books so
so
so that's one claim to fame but let's
open up for questions
we have a question here on the right
three questions first of all how old was
she
perhaps when she died
and the second question is did they ever
do an audit of her estate when she died
because she lived in the 15th and the
third question is did the media french
media ever do an interview ever
okay the first question was how old she
was when she died she was born in 1924
and she died before her
birthday in 2011 so she was 86 and a
half
um
she
the second one was the audit of her
um
sorry oh she lives in the 15 hour oh
which is um
which is just across the street from the
most posh neighborhood which is the
seventh
and she lived in a apartment that she
was very cagey about how she came to
have the apartment she said it was a
gift and the way she described it it
made it sound like she thought the cia
or the americans or someone had bought
it for her in in some small consolation
prize for
everything um
uh
there there does seem to be pretty
conclusive evidence though that the
family in general was not corrupt they
were not
um stealing money out of the country
there were no swiss bank accounts
they had
put money in to buy some land outside of
rome
for some sort of religious retreat that
they envisioned um they would bring
vietnamese monks from vietnam to rome um
so it was it wasn't like
it wasn't like there were stacks of gold
somewhere
and now i've forgotten your third
question
[Music]
um they did but nothing after 1986
madame news memoirs are coming out in
french though um
this november
um they are being published by her
children and and a family friend and
they're um i'm sorry i'm blanking on the
name of the publishing house um
but they are coming out in french in
november
first of all you mentioned
poor children
and took care of two of them but what
happened to the other two
and then second question is has your
book been translated into vietnamese to
be published in vietnam
uh first question about the children um
so she has two sons that are left living
and
uh the oldest czech lives
i believe still on the italian property
there was there's some question of
property rights and boundaries
and so i think he's sort of the defender
of the estate
and the uh
the younger son he went to business
school and he worked for procter gamble
in belgium for
several years and so he's very uh i
guess cosmopolitan
european
um
and and and living a a life over there
uh translated book
uh as i said i'm not sure if my book is
going to be well received in vietnam i i
come down hard pretty much on everyone i
come down pretty hard on the south
vietnamese family the americans the
french the communists sort of no one
no one gets off easy um so but i'm not
sure that that will be liked enough to
be translated i'll officially translate
it
i'll come back to
testing
i was fascinated to hear that you were
in the archives in france my first
question were they receptive
and did they clue you that there might
be stuff that they won't release until
like our american national archives we
have
sensitive records that are only released
every so often uh through a committee so
i'm kind of curious if you're monitoring
that to see if any new stuff is coming
out
uh so my french research took place in
two main archives one is that the in
not very nicely titled the chat archives
the service historique de la me de la
terre or something like that and it's in
vasen just outside of paris and those
are really the army um the army archives
and then there's the colonial archives
in exxon provence
which has all of the
as much as they could get out of vietnam
before 1954. um they know that a lot was
lost
through the cracks
and in fact
it's all sort of so suspicious still
when i went to go look for madame news
husbands dossier
they found it and i did the derogation
and i did the you know
the french bureaucracy i can say this as
having dual nationality the french
bureaucracy is just mind-boggling and so
it's much easier to do research in
american archives than in france but um
the next year i went back because i had
been approved and they found the file
and i got to france and it was
officially missing and as far as i know
it's still missing so
thank you
are any members of madame news extended
family still in vietnam and in fact did
any of them
uh during the war support the other side
i don't i don't know the answer to that
question i know that the um
the noel family there were there were oh
my goodness
10
brothers and sisters or something so i'm
sure that there are descendants of them
and in fact one of um
one of ziem's nephews became pretty high
up in the catholic church and i'm so
embarrassed that i'm not up to speed
enough on my catholic um
hierarchy but he became he became a
really well-known
bishop i think um but but a big deal um
so he uh he was definitely still in
vietnam
question in the back
when the east west center association
was in hanoi
uh four years ago
our ambassador told us america has no
better friend in asia than vietnam
and i wondered how you felt received
there you told me
earlier that you went a lot as a child
and how did you feel you were received
in recent time
uh well
the
the vietnamese people that i met in
vietnam were never anything but
wonderful to me um
there was my first trip to vietnam was
in 1997 and at that time there was a lot
of resentment towards russians
but not so much towards americans so i
think perhaps um
this is very much just my interpretation
but i think because they were successful
in the war and because i studied in
hanoi there was perhaps an easier
forgiveness in some sense in hanoi
towards americans than there is in
america towards vietnam um because
they they sort of got what they were
looking for which was a
unified country under communist rule
um so
i i don't
i certainly think that um vietnam is a
strategic ally with the united states
there's a lot of
power dynamics in asia
and america needs some um
it needs to needs to balance things out
so
yeah
hi um i know that she's a very complex
person but would you describe her as
being a feminist
yes because i think the word feminist to
me means uh defender of women's rights
and uh and pro-woman and so i'm not sure
madame knew would have used that word to
describe herself but
to in my interpretation
yes she was
in your conversations with her did she
ever have an opinion or remark to you
about what she thought about the
modernization of vietnam and how things
are going in the country now and did she
ever express a longing to return home
no she did not express a longing to ever
go back to vietnam as it is now she
expressed um
sadness that she would never see her her
house again and the place where she had
grown up but um to madame knew the the
path that vietnam had taken was you know
the path to hell i mean she was like
convinced
that there was gonna be another war or
or the apocalypse
are there any other questions um
andrew do you have any other queries
well i i think it's great uh that we
having nearing 40th anniversary at the
end of the vietnam war that there are
more literature that comes out that
explore the complexity of that past i
wish there were more
young people who are intellectually
curious about the vietnam war because we
need this kind of
sort of
intellectual investigation into the past
as a way to create new conversation
about understanding or not understanding
so many wars that we continue to wage
i i agree and i think that um the 50th
anniversary commemorations start this
year of um so um it was 50 years ago
that the coup happened in saigon that
toppled
the ngo regime from power so
50 years ago was this sort of turning
point into the vietnam war as we know it
that was kind of a decisive moment when
america got
really involved so i think that we will
see more the department of defense is
doing a big hoopla in washington and um
i think there's going to be a lot of
awareness raising nick terse just wrote
that
really powerful book on vietnam um so
yeah i think there's i think the there's
more to come
great thank you so much
um nick teres he wrote a book this year
called um kill anything that moves
and it was um
a research on into the american side
into
their actions in vietnam
well
thank you so much for talking with us
and good luck with your book tour thank
you
[Applause]
on behalf of mechanics institute and
asia society thank you for coming and we
look forward to seeing you at our next
event
[Applause]
[Music]
so please come up books are for sale